[Music]
you
[Music]
all right well thanks for joining me
today
well you guys and so I'm gonna start
with the first question what were some
of your favorite movies growing up with
you know awesome Asian bad guys die hard
al Allen die hard was awesome knows he
was also in lethal weapon I mean he's my
favorite awesome Asian bad guys by far
he's the one that like I would always
see his little kid and so just to
identify I kind of with like this
mysterious dude and then see him and
then to meet him and stuff has been
pretty cool we actually shot a video
with him like this afternoon so it's
pretty fun you're talking about Ali oh
yeah Ali oh oh yeah he's really well
easily recognizable because he's got the
Foo Manchu hair and for me Big Trouble
in Little China is like the pinnacle of
Asian bad guys cuz there's so many of
them and there's even Asian good guys in
it and it's sort of a typical you never
would really see that but Big Trouble in
Little China definitely stands out as a
cool movie from that was young well next
question aside from creating a badass
film what do you hope to accomplish with
this um you know do you hope to
contribute in any way like to kind of
change how Asian Americans are viewed in
mainstream media idle ladies are like
any idealistic goal aside from just a
passion project yeah I mean I think that
like you know when we talk about oh we
want to you know talk about bring
together these Asian bad guys people
might think originally that we're doing
like a documentary you know and it's
like exploring like the role of Asians
and Hollywood from before and we're not
doing that because wow that would be
cool it would also be you know not as
much fun so it's not what we wanted to
our style yeah so we do want to tell the
stories of these awesome Asian bad guys
and do it in a fun way so that's why
it's this action comedy web series it's
scripted and
and we want to get their story out but
we don't want to do it by kind of
hitting people over the head and saying
hey back in the day they're not you want
to make it fun and engaging and you know
what we want to do as well is kind of
start a conversation about wow you know
this is how Asians were portrayed let's
say in the 80s you know like 20-30 years
ago this is what it looked like to be an
Asian American working Asian American
actor you had get killed in every movie
you're in all of your Bruce Lee unless
you're Bruce Lee but you're exactly but
you know we want to say hey what's you
know this is how it was before you know
how is it changed how is the power
things today
and or you know how are they also still
the same right and I mean wow imagine
produced Lee actually lived in face of
like Asian pop culture would be really
different but I think also it's like you
know like like like you said I mean
we're a little bit older than you so
it's like we grew up with these people
and we kind of like eventually found out
who they were their names and stuff just
out of curiosity and it's like there's
people that recognize them but then like
let's kind of bring bring them put the
spotlight on they're not necessarily in
this kind of you know like explain like
the this didactic way of like Asian m101
type stuff but but in a way where it's
like oh I recognize this guy let me find
out a little bit more about them if I
want to be like people are really really
like you know every generation is more
and more media savvy so it's like you
don't need to be like you know drilled
in the head with like who these people
are and the plight that they went
through and whatnot we're all aware of
that but at least like you know let's
let's have some fun with it and like
let's let's uh give these guys like
they're this is this kind of comedic
moment to have you know right that's
awesome
cool I mean um you know that speaking of
which um you know you guys have some you
know pretty talented professionals on
board already you know like a young
obviously is there like a specific actor
like you want to get into this project
that's not involved with it yet there's
a few there's a few you know we've
brought on a couple awesome Asian bad
guys so far but there's there's
definitely more we want to you know
more people like so bolo oh of course
so bolo apparently lives in Southern
California and we'd love to work with
bolo we haven't figured out a way to
reach him quite yet but we'd love to
work with bolo haven't be part of this
there's a character to Iowa who like he
was in black rain he was known about the
Mortal Kombat and Jorge Cheung he's just
he was like in Rambo - he gets blown
apart
always laying a grenade launcher or some
kind of our peach it's like it's it's
actually I think a like tipped you know
arrow right like explosive arrow nice if
that's how you're gonna go out that's a
good way to go yeah that's pretty unique
so if you actually track down and like
look for Austin Asian bad guys the list
is really long
alright and there's tons and like
there's more like since we you know can
be kind of like decided to go ahead with
this with this project and bringing uh
you know people on board like you know
other movies come out like well they're
finally releasing movies like the Red
Dawn reboot you know and all the bad
guys are like well they went from being
Chinese to North Korean and then movies
like was a Wolverine
we're like in shooting now yes shooting
now we're all the you know bad guys are
Asian even like you know I mean not that
it's like a big deal because the
Mandarin has always been a good
character in the Iron Man in like world
but you know him being played by Ben
Kingsley right so yeah there's just
there's tons of Asian bad guys and if
there's gonna be more and more well you
know that's a good that's a good point
like there's tons of Asian American tons
of Asian bad guys there right now so you
know that kind of follows my next
question who would you say is your
favorite Asian villain of all time I
know you kind of touched on this but you
know who if you could pick one who would
it be
let me think
actually okay so okay know what talking
about the actors but just about villains
Storm Shadow do you ever see what he
looks like
I don't know yeah mystery yeah but it's
just like you know into like his costume
was white right right right
it was just like so cool right yeah I
mean mine mine might be the James Hong
character in it well kind of in in a big
trouble Oh China and then also in in his
little bit in Wayne's World Wayne's
World one two two goes to your career
that stuff was just funny you know like
it's all kind of bit where it was kind
of like a early 90s omage to the 70s
kung fu movies you know when with the
ridiculous
martial arts and you know like effects
and bad dubbing and all that jazz so you
know that might be one of my favorite
scenes of all time like I was kind of
doing a little bit of research on you
guys than anything you guys seems I've
been getting a lot of support for ever
my and reagent man and doesn't have any
specific involvement with this project
at all he doesn't he does he's our
executive producer for this OH
so Phil so we've been doing these videos
for about a year we had our we put out a
video called the awesome Asian bad guys
last year and he was really into in a
bunch of our other videos and you know
so you know we're all kind of like the
same interest like 80s 90s pop culture
nostalgia movies and an Asian stuff on
that tip so when we kind of you know had
this idea we thought he'd be like a
great person just to have on our team
and he's totally down for it and he's
been like awesome to have just helping
us get the word out and just the support
and the positive vibes it's been a who
wouldn't be where we are right now like
without his help yeah I know Phil's a
great guy man yeah actually today
you just changed is that landing page on
angry Asian man calm and it just just as
awesome Asian bad guys just yeah a big
red page with our logo
I saw it feels a great guy so I mean
like Molly and I know but no other
person no impersonally to so he's always
been really supportive yeah so that's
great and you know speaking of which
congratulations on reaching over half
your target goal I mean like right there
you know obviously there's a lot of
support and everything but amongst your
friends and I'm just like your your
friends in the community in general like
what's been the general feedback like
have you received anything you know all
those mostly positive have you received
anything negative at all I mean I think
join this no I mean I'm not during this
campaign you know we're still like it
still like relatively new the whole
project you know we've been kind of
developing it for only a few months and
and then you know got put together a
couple of videos and then launched this
Kickstarter and you know what's been
really interesting is like we thought
initially at least I did that you know
it would really be just like people we
knew and like in the asian-american
community that would help support but
what's been really awesome is to just
find like random people why white guys
or not you know Asian who just see this
and they're like oh my god that's the
most amazing thing right and and
something that has been cool it's like
you know the this is kind of like how it
started with our even starting like our
Facebook fan page early on it was like
oh these are all people that names I
recognize and then just like the
Kickstarter it started out that way and
now it's like a whole bunch of people I
have no idea who the hell they are which
is which is bloody fantastic and we're
really excited about that because you
know we know that we're kind of the all
the work that we've been putting into it
all the help that we've been getting
from from everyone um sharing it and
putting it out there that it's been
paying off that's good oh you know so as
we know this is a webseries right and no
it's a comedy web series and it's like a
you said it was a match between the
Expendables and dumb and dumber correct
so I'm gonna kind of hit you with a
curveball here do you think the film
would be successful if it was just
purely
action film and no and without the
comedy element into it okay sure
maybe I mean well thing is like we I
mean we do like comedy you know and so
it's kind of like our bent and stuff if
like somebody who's like up here you
here's like X dollars you're making an
action thing yeah I mean we'd make it
but I mean it's it wouldn't be like it
wouldn't really have like like our kind
of flavor our kind of like our mark on
it you know what I mean if we took the
comedy out of it you know cool all right
none of the many of the talents like
you're starring have worked mainly in
traditional media um aside from your
partnership with like PBS are there any
other reasons why he chose to make this
into a webseries instead of a future
film yes
in a future before is called mr. sad man
and that thing I mean it took me like
eight years to do from the time I put
pen to paper to the time I actually got
it onto iTunes and Amazon and it just
becomes like this huge albatross around
your neck and it was it was great as
great learning experience and like I'd
love to do another one
someday soon but it's like you know when
we started doing these online videos
last year's National Film Society we
just kind of realized I mean we got onto
the online video because of the the
swiftness of it and the light the
lightness of the production the feel and
even if it's you know even even though
like we will take put as much work into
this as we would a feature film there's
just like that kind of connotation and
that vibe around it where if it's it's a
five-part web series as opposed to like
this feature film where in people's
minds sometimes it becomes like this
larger thing and there's certain things
that you should do to get that may you
know what I mean and this is kind of
contextualized it differently from us it
makes it doable when you say oh we're
making a feature of done when you're
like oh my god it's gonna be huge thing
what do you say oh we're making a
webseries it feels like okay yeah like
let's do that that's that's gonna be fun
it just makes it the whole thing to see
more fun and
and doable it also allows you to kind of
grow organically - you know with the
lower budget yeah yeah and I mean in all
honesty its border like the the total
length will be shorter than a feature
film for the for this first chunk of
cierra episodes awesome well yeah I mean
that's pretty much it I mean aside from
all the all this is there anything any
anything that we can look forward to any
like surprises that we that we don't
know yet like do you have like let's say
a talent that you having an out set that
just came on board or you know you have
any exciting news to share I guess
that's my question um the the main thing
is you know we are just making a really
hard push over the next few days to get
the word out on this awesome Asian bad
guys Kickstarter it ends on Thursday
October 11th at 9 p.m. Pacific and so
between now and then you know we're
gonna be doing a lot we have a couple
new videos coming out with yu-gi-oh
Komodo we just put out today and with
Ally young or are two main awesome Asian
bad guys and the whole kick starter
experience is uh crazy it's just crazy
because if we don't hit the goal we're
not gonna get any of the money so it's
gonna be fun so watch how this goes down
and super stressful for us a lot of
entertainment for everyone else out
there to see to see us do it and you
know we we encourage everybody to check
out the Kickstarter campaign and you
know consider pledging their support to
this project cuz it's gonna be it's
gonna be awesome
yeah and it's it'll be cool yeah six or
maybe like you know five to half days
from now you know up until like Steve
said October 11th and it's like every
day we're gonna be I've been saying this
for a couple days now just gonna go out
guns blazing and will be a you know
hopefully just hopefully we'll get there
you know we will get there pretty well
get there oh you guys you guys will be
fine
yeah I'm sure it's cool well great I
mean like well thanks a lot for talking
to me I appreciate it and yeah that's
about Thank You Man thank you let us
know if you need
photos or anything
you